the thing about men who get sent away
the war is some of them don't come back
at all
there's so many of us they'll never get
us all out mrs. Cole cut uh where is she
could someone please get mr. Hilliard
out of Dunkirk welcome to the mystery of
information film division mr. Churchill
is persuaded that film control this is a
war America shouldn't be fighting if we
were to capture the public imagination
and their trust we need a story to
inspire a nation Dunkirk evacuation of
troops trapped by the German advance
very good I just wonder if it might mean
back on the wall punch Dunkirk
the miracle look put the fire back in
all our bellies you know how it starts
twin sisters took their father's boat
over to join the rescue we know how it
ends
338,000 home safe now all we have to do
fill in the gaps mrs. Cole we'll need
someone to write the slot so Girl Talk
women's dialogue I thought it was a
secretarial post we've got sake you got
yourself Uncle Frank a shipwreck of a
man
60s looks oh god we all have a part of
90 feet in hip not this part it's a
corpse Rory's dead before the end of act
3 so long lose half which half oh we
don't need
people like films because stories
estructure things turn bad it's still
part of the plan
as a point to it all those people gave
their sons to one war and now their
grandsons to another without them
weeping in the aisles
mrs. Cole I thought she was under it
just can't do this team or the works
good none of them could have done any
better
you and me given opportunities only
because young men are gone but to turn
our back on those opportunities
wouldn't that be giving death dominion
over life if all of this stopped I'd
miss it I'd miss you do you really have
to smoke that thing up I mean Quinn
Church is mine I can mind smoking I
can't mine smoke damn flurry strong
readings but your absence at several
events sorry my dad had an episode and I
was home helping out is that related to
his MS I've been looking into your
parents situation